I'm here with dr. David agus who's
professor of engineering and medicine at
at USC and we're looking at pictures
here of things that seem very different
to me what what what what is the
commonality right here the commonality
is inflammation so inflammation can be
manifest by a runny nose and a cold or
getting the flu it could be manifest by
an infection in your toes
it could be hitting your head playing
football or hitting your arm when you
fall playing a sport all of those can
cause inflammation and I want to because
inflammation has a certain meaning in
everyday language it kind of means what
at least when I imagine it means
something is swollen and red but here
we're talking about inflammation and
more of the medical or the scientific
sense where it's not things are swollen
and red because of inflammation right
and and what so what is inflammation it
isn't just swollen and redness you're
talking about it I'm een you know
football player isn't getting swollen in
red or is or is he so inflammation was
your body senses danger so when
something is wrong whether it be an
infection whether it be trauma in a case
of football players whether it be a cold
your body senses danger and sends in its
frontline soldiers which are the immune
cells in order to fight whatever is
causing it so if it's trauma the immune
cells go in there and they help rebuild
the tissue that's damaged if it's
bacteria that go in there and they try
to take away the bacteria so you can get
over that cold or that flu and so that
whole process we call inflammation it's
not a senior process so the immune cells
going to the sign of danger to either
fight the danger itself or repair the
after Matt yeah of the date so that
sounds like a good thing it's an awesome
thing the problem is your body all of us
we care about what happens today not
down the road right this is you know one
of the take-home points that astonish me
when I start to think about it is that
nature evolution selects out for who has
good kids and that's what evolution is
about is that about having children we
call progeny right it's not about what
happens when you're 80 years old or 90
years old right and so inflammation is
fantastic about dealing with today's
ramifications right the problem is if
you get the flu today your risk of
cancer and heart disease a decade or two
decades from now or up if I get the flu
once if you get the flu once
really so those five six days when you
feel horrible your inflammation is
through the roof right that's having
ramifications down the road right and I
mean just to take a sign this is already
getting a little scary for me because
I've had the flu so I already feel
worried about my can't you tell by
looking at you and I looked at that but
but and and the the symptoms that we get
when we have the flu or cold these are
actually it's not the viruses the virus
is causing the inflammation which is
causing the symptoms
yeah and that's what's wild is that when
you get a virus your immune system
attacks it and then you get a fever I
still don't know why we get fevers it's
one of those things where that we call
the cytokines which are proteins the
immune cells make to send out and get
more reinforcements and tell the body
what to do it causes a fever is it fever
good is it fever bad I don't know we
take tylenol to lower a fever but is
that a good thing nobody really has
looked at the long-term ramifications
they look at short-term but how does it
affect a decade from now what's going to
happen
we just don't know Wow well and what
you're saying is is that the reason why
we have inflammation is yeah something
has happened to my body has some trauma
some injury and you were setting this to
go you might have to run away from a
lion tomorrow so fix fix fix Sal or fix
David up right now so that you can run
away from the line tomorrow but it you
know in in in in the wild I might have a
live to 40 anyway so so why even worry
about whether that person might get
cancer if they get to 40 or 50 once
they're past the age of rejection body
has to choose priorities right priority
clearly is today rather than tomorrow
right and so an amazing study was done
in that we gave patients what we call a
statin so statins were drugs st atin
they were drugs that were developed
because they block the synthesis of
cholesterol right and we thought you
know people with higher cholesterol
particularly the bad one called LDL
those people have a higher incidence of
heart disease so if we block the
synthesis we're going to affect heart
disease and what do you know we did a
dramatic effect where we lowered the
death from heart disease with these
drugs right so it seems like they worked
it worked that a company or a very
clever group did a trial where they gave
people with normal cholesterol these
drugs right and they had a dramatic
effect
that Adelaide heart attack and stroke by
almost a dozen years Wow and it reduced
the incidence of cancer by about 40
percent so cancer something I mean we
don't associate cholesterol Wow so it
turns out these drugs which were the
biggest drug in terms of sales we've
ever had right
worked by lowering inflammation so
they're affected heart disease wasn't by
lowering cholesterol it was
predominantly bellowing inflammation
right and the effect on cancer was by
lowering inflammation in fact remember
when the swine flu came out a couple
years ago right right so if you got the
swine flu the only thing that protected
you from your lungs collapsing and going
on we call a ventilator a breathing
machine was being on one of these
statins it would stop the inflammation
swine flu people were dying from this
inflammation going nuts yeah and and so
that this is fastly
it isn't even necessarily the people who
are dying of heart disease is it
necessarily the cholesterol that's
killing them or is it the the
inflammation that's causing plaque it's
this chicken in the egg fin right right
right
the inflammation allows cholesterol to
deposit rise together
I see so really it's really the statin
affects inflammation inflammation which
then which then reduces cancer by
stopping the inflammation and stopping
though exactly what are those problems
we have in biology you know medicine
it's what you can measure right so I can
measure cholesterol right I don't really
know how to measure inflammation well
right so while we can make these
Association and big studies when we look
back if I had a metric if I had a blood
test or something to look at for
inflammation I can optimize things can
do not measure just the amount of
cytokines and other inflammatory type of
type of things that become increased in
your eyes right happened your different
types of information right so I see some
inflammation can be good some can be bad
some can be really causal right some
could be a little bit causal and so
we're putting them all into one basket
now which is inflammation the key is to
start to tease them out and be able to
modulate them you know you could develop
a drug but then you have to optimize it
for a particular purpose right right so
these were optimized to lower
cholesterol and they do that very well
they also lower inflammation and they
work beautifully in that regard but how
do we optimize
going for right what it also means is
that when you look at your lifestyle and
my lifestyle we have to limit
inflammation right so what are the easy
ways to do that one is which I think
should be mandatory things like the flu
shot right so again the flu shot will
certainly delay you from having to
prevent you from having bad flu that's
good today and good tomorrow tomorrow
yeah it's heart disease and cancer down
the road that's did that I did add no
clue that the flu I thought was just a
nice thing avoid a week of sneezing and
you know but flu shot you can actually
reduce your cancer and heart disease
down the road and then we have to think
long term as a society what about
statins I mean it seems like these are
drugs like lipitor Crestor and you hear
that you see the so I mean would you I
mean I meant no one should take our
medical advice based on a thing in a
video but right I mean is is it are
people taking it just for heart disease
or are people taking it more broadly now
listen I mean I'm a believer that these
drugs have such a profound effect on
cancer heart disease stroke potentially
Alzheimer's that you should consider
taking it to prevent these diseases
right and again giving no
recommendations but what I say is you
your parents they should talk about with
their doctor right and so why shouldn't
I be on this drug right and there are
some side effects but they could they're
easy to test for and they're test for
and then they're reversible right okay
so you're not going anything you got to
do a risk and a benefit right and you
have to look at you and say am i high
risk for XYZ if you are what can prevent
it or delay it right the name of the
game is not treating disease it's
preventing disease right right that's
this is fascinating i well I might talk
to my wife about getting some well no no
advice here everyone should talk to
their doctor hahaha I mean by the way
another great medicine to reduce
inflammation is called aspirin aspirin
I've heard of that that's a hell of a
drug again there's side effects to
aspirin can affect bleeding but at the
same time it's a dramatic effect by
lowering inflammation right and that
that is its main side effect I'm is this
age-old drug it's made it's a blood
thinner so if you you get a cut or you
bleed or while you have why you're
taking aspirin that you might bleed more
right blood thinners a funny term I'm
not quite sure to me thinking paint
thinner when you suffer done how it
it binds to the platelets and blocks
them from activating I stopped them from
working really was more anti-clotting
write and play those are one of the key
components of clotting they certainly
affect it right so your blood will have
the same viscosity won't just won't clot
as easily exactly and you can certainly
paint a wall with either one that's a
little morbid all right well that thanks
a bunch